monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues porno l'enfer du
décor ou comment résumer en 5 mots le
rapport choc que notre délégation au
droit des femmes a publié en septembre
dernier mot d'une industrie licencieuse
qui prospère en irrigant la toile de
contenu illicite avec mes trois
collègues co rapporteur Alexandra borque
Fontain Laurence Cohen Laurence
Rossignol nous avons pour la première
fois dans l'histoire parlementaire
enquêté pendant 6 mois sur la réalité
des pratiques de l'industrie
pornographique nous avons entendu toutes
les parties prenantes dont à huis clos
des victimes de l'affaire French boukake
cette affaire a permis de mettre au
grand jour les pratiques de producteurs
de barbares qui ont détruit la vie de
dizaines de femmes
nous avons analysé les principaux
contenus disponibles sur les sites
pornographiques ces plateformes en ligne
les tubes qui proposent gratuitement et
sans aucun contrôle des millions de
vidéos il faut sortir de toute vision
datée
du porno le porno aujourd'hui ce sont
des contenus violents dégradants
humiliant les scènes dans lesquelles un
homme ou plus souvent des hommes
infligent des violences physiques et
sexuelles à des femmes sont devenus la
norme la pornographie n'est pas du
cinéma les pleurs les cris les viols le
sang il n'y a pas d'effets spéciaux tout
est vrai ce sont ces violences et leur
banalisation qui nous ont amenés à
prendre des positions fortes notre
rapport a eu un écho médiatique
considérable en France et à
l'international suscitant une onde de
choc dans l'opinion
le nombre de cossignataires de cette
proposition de résolution
255 exactement
constituent un record jamais atteint
pour un sexe pardon pour un texte
sénatorial sous la Cinquième République
excusez-moi ce lapsus
ce chiffre témoigne d'une prise de
conscience collective plus que d'inviter
il engage le gouvernement à mettre en
oeuvre les recommandations que nous
avons formulées les ministres à qui nous
avons présenté le rapport nous ont
assuré vouloir avancer sur ce sujet je
pense bien sûr à la sulution de contrôle
d'âge annoncé récemment par Jean-Noël
Barrault et Charlotte cobel ainsi qu'à
toutes les mesures de politiques pénale
qui permettront de poursuivre les
auteurs et diffuseurs la massification
de la production et de la consommation
nous oblige je sais pouvoir compter sur
vous madame la ministre vous partagez
notre détermination nos propositions
sont sur la table le gouvernement doit
s'en saisir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]